and only eight news now was there as one
man accused of multiple sex crimes was
taken into custody the eight news now
investigators have uncovered another
twist in this case Vanessa Murphy
explains from the Regional Justice
Center
Carlos Nava came here to court out of
custody for a case in which he's accused
of sexually assaulting a sex worker he
left in handcuffs as an accused serial
rapist that's while Federal authorities
say he's in the U.S illegally and has
re-entered multiple times I'm going to
call Carlos Nava Carlos Nava here for
his case dating back to July Metro
Police say he sexually assaulted and
kidnapped a woman he was buying sex from
turns out Navas now accused of four
additional sexual assaults one of them a
cold case from 2003. Mr Nava now
essentially might have as much as
combined Act of sexual assaults and all
of these sexual assaults involved
individuals who was working as a
processor at that time prosecutor
William Rawls says Nava's DNA matches
those cases the 8 news now investigators
learned those crimes are alleged to have
happened while he was in the U.S
illegally according to Immigration and
Customs Enforcement he's re-entered at
least eight times since 2002. this is an
email from an ice spokesperson
describing Nava's history you can see
how long it is Nava's been discovered by
law enforcement in California Arizona
and Las Vegas arrests include charges
for battery and domestic violence the
last known time Nava was in the U.S and
then removed in 2020 after his arrest
last July records show judge Daniel
westmeyer granted bail Nava was placed
on electronic monitoring and was able to
walk out of jail that's while police
said they were looking for more victims
members of our community since 2003 Nava
learning about the new allegations
against him through an interpreter the
victim in the initial case a no-show
because there are more alleged victims
including one under the age of 16 years
old police in plain clothes were
standing by ready to take Nava into
custody again
did he rape these women did you rape
these
the judge saying if the victim in that
first case doesn't show up here in court
to testify that case will be dismissed
reporting in downtown Las Vegas at the
Regional Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now